[Music]
you
[Music]
welcome to meme review everybody
YouTube's favorite show let's
investigate how the last one did
copyrighted just like I thought it would
because of that stupid meme kid the
stupid apparently you're not allowed to
review things even though it's
specifically a review built as a review
made as a review you can't claim the
revenue you can't review things
apparently done this platform great you
know
you know take the money I don't want I
don't what the money I don't take
we live in a society I don't know if you
guys have noticed this
I have level three Volk yeah we live in
our society I think we could probably
all agree that we live in our society
we're live in a society this is a meme
now apparently this is great can I
review the meme what am I going to be
the roof you drew a few fresh memes then
no one will understand what I'm talking
about
we live in a society we live in a
society a society we live in it
we live in a society a society we live
in II just try and debunk this you can't
it's impossible we live in a society
guys you might ask yourself where is the
joke well that's exactly it apparently
used to look like this we live in a
society where three thinkers open-minded
people are called crazy and the ignorant
closed mind people that call norm wrong
and then they just remove the actual
context but we got a selfish this is
what we have this is the absolute state
of memes I'm not complaining I'm just
saying this is it this is the state of
memes are you happy I'm not I never been
help me hey girls
did you know that your boobs we live in
a society we live in a society I keep
telling everyone that we live in a
society but no one seems to lease it
I've been doing pew news that's trust a
news source and we're all trying to get
the message across that we live in a
society we live in a society if you're
if you didn't know it from me just take
it from the loved' character George
Costanza from the 90s sitcom Seinfeld
you know we're living in a society
because the selected group of people can
go oh I know what that's from but maybe
not everyone so therefore I'm part of
this secret a little joke club called
memes so funny now it's funny because
not everyone gets it we're living in a
society
we're supposed to act in a civilized way
thank you george costanza we live in a
society we're supposed to act in a
civilized way you may think we try to
live in a society here thank you George
thank you this society meme of course
we'll have to get a zero
wait it guess what is gets a one because
we live in a society one society just
like one earth which is not flat done'
hey buddy hey I know you I know what
you're thinking
will there be bonus meme this week
there's been literally weeks without
bonus and I could really use a bonus
meat this week just I'm with you I
understand I feel the same I feel the
same pain and suffering it hurts
it doesn't feel very good but we must be
strong and endure it because we live in
a society next meme suck memes are back
for the third time damn damn
this damn Daniel that's awesome
Sacre vasista meme that just keeps on
giving it's been transformed and skewed
into all these kinds of areas of memes
but now sorry Mark Zuckerberg had to
testify in front of the Congress does
anyone then really know why private
company right like why does he have to
do anything I don't understand how many
data categories do you store does
Facebook store on the categories that
you clicked senator I'm not actually
sure what that is referring to but we
basically were blessed with five hours
of footage of Mark Zuckerberg wishes
let's - a lot of beautiful memes very
Buda more material the more memes as I
always say on this channel that's the
rule of the means now where do you even
begin with the suck mean let's start
with the hair you know you gotta go on
television Congress and all that you got
to get yourself a nice haircut I don't
know what that haircut is cold but I am
next time I'm going through the barber
and I'm showing them a picture of this
because that's that's what I want second
of all of course he looked like he's
normal awkward self I don't know how
it's possible but he looks like a mutant
from fallout but of course you may say
well anyone examined by so many cameras
will just seem crazy for some people oh
no no no no no no no don't excuse these
are the people that subscribe to them
quietly the mainstream media idea that
Mark Zuckerberg isn't in fact a robot or
reptilian we haven't confirmed which one
yet looks like an effing horror movie
poster like what is this he must
patrolling how do you
shot like that otherwise there is no
place to run
Zack I wanted to see this film I
genuinely was the third most beautiful
thing where your blade was the fact that
sucks sat on a booster seat but it's
just cute he's sitting on a booster seat
that's adorable
I mean to be fair if you're gonna sit
five hours and got to keep a straight
posture in front of cameras I would want
a booster seat too if someone asked me
hey dude
you might want to take this I'll be like
I have my three nine to nine chair right
here guys have I told you buy my 399
chair I will have I told you about ass
it's coming out on Gameboy switch check
it out everybody I think you'll enjoy
ass damn that boy is sick we've been
lucky lately honestly like from the
boogie down challenge to the suck memes
things I'm gonna bring up tomorrow I'm
just a we live in a society now given
its it's just trying to live in a
society here some especially woke people
pointed out that this is not a booster
seat guys please if your family or
friends are watching please put on
headphones right now it's not a booster
seat
it's a wireless charging mechanism how
else do you think he can be going for
five hours straight
this of course confirms the theory that
Jacques is a robot collecting data
honors all of you against me you cannot
fast travel with an amusement what you
see what what you see versus what he
sees hmm some people have hacked his
mind
but only for a brief second warning
system overheating must add coolant to
regulate hello at this point
mark can't do anything without being
criticized or ridiculed or he drank
water what is he gonna do next yes
it's too good luck is just a mean that
keeps on giving and we should all be
thankful I don't know what I'd rated the
suck meme the first time I reviewed it
but it's definitely gotten at least +2
sucks on that baby that's right let's
see where will it go in the future
hmm who knows do we have time for bonus
meme the biggest question of the year
it's been four weeks Felix we need a
bonus mean please
we would really need a book okay let me
just read or Brad - do we have time for
boaters me calling upon Brad and Brad -
is it time it's time dropping your phone
in front of the mirror and then turning
it into stranger things
[Music]
now I have a strange hunch that this
music of stranger things it's
copyrighted very heavily in that some
third party or at least not maybe
they're kind of the producers are somes
itself will come in and claim this
entire video because of using of this
track and if I do your little schmuck
music Holly kid if you're watching I
will personally find you and snap your
father
[Music]
goddamnit this that's not very Christian
[Music]
Wow
okay all right defense fight that is so
funny
thanks and for voters mean we're like
for you to play equal breath we're we
thank you for watching another video but
main review and remember to smile more
often